alright guys so I've gotten a lot of
requests to do a specific video about my
most anticipated films of 2013 and since
I started last week a new segment called
movie news I wanted to continue that
this week but there wasn't really any
big news stories so this week instead of
talking about some superfluous news
story that you guys don't care about I'm
gonna give you guys the news of my most
anticipated films of this year now the
January is gone I feel like I can
actually do that oh another cool thing I
want to do with this movie news segment
is give a mention to a channel that I
think is deserving or that you guys
maybe would be interested in watching
and I'm gonna try to start doing that
once a week because you guys are
freaking sweet and before I get into my
most anticipated films I'm gonna talk to
you guys about a channel over at Cinna
fix and this channel is especially
wonderful for us men or women who are
attracted to other girls I came across
this channel hosted by Arianna Celeste
now you guys may know who that is if you
read Playboy magazine or have the
internet like I do
I do not read Playboy magazine but I do
have the internet now let me explain a
little bit about this show I will try to
do my best to focus while that is
playing when was the last time your
knowledge got a woman to take her
clothes off
for us men or women who enjoy the female
form it is a nice show in which we can
answer movie related trivia and watch a
woman reward us by removing articles of
clothing so I put an annotation for you
guys to enjoy that you're welcome now as
I said I will try to give more mentions
to channels that I think you guys will
enjoy in the following weeks when I do
my movie news segment but let's get into
our most anticipated films of 2013 the
first movie I want to talk about is
coming out pretty soon actually February
14th that's a good day to die hard and
this film could go both ways I don't
know honestly when I watched this
trailer it looks very special effects
heavy but it still looks like it just
has a little bit of the die-hard John
McClane vibe and I'm hoping that it's
good I really want it to be good I'm
scared I guess but I just I want this
movie to be a lot of fun it's cool did
it's rated R again even though diehard 4
actually was able to cram a lot of die
hardness into it even though it was a
little too special-effects see towards
the end I still enjoyed that film for
what it was die hard 5 I'm hoping really
hoping gives me what I want now on April
12th there's a special early IMAX
release of Tom Cruise's new film
oblivion I am really interested in this
film purely because the talent involved
Morgan Freeman's in this film Tom Cruise
obviously is one of my favorite actors
but this movie just looks really good
and interesting it looks a little bit
almost Space Odyssey ish with a little
bit more entertainment value like it
looks like there's gonna be a lot of
those really futuristic realistic
science-fiction not like the big you
know like over-the-top science-fiction
that are entertaining nowadays this
movie just looks intense it looks fun
and I am excited to see what Tom Cruise
has up his sleeve for this film now on
April 26 this is a film that I can't
even believe I'm saying is on my list
simply because of the director this
director is Michael Bay and this film is
pain and gain it looks kind of fun it
looks like the kind of movie that I
would love Michael Bay to stay with of
course he decided to make a second
Transformers trilogy nevertheless painin
game does look like it's a lot of fun
mark wahlberg dwayne johnson are these
body builders and they get in trouble
with the law
mark wahlberg has proven with ted that
he's very good with comedy dwayne
johnson looks like he's playing one of
those roles where he is the big
guy but he doesn't like to fight he
doesn't like guns he's gonna faint or
whatever if he gets too close to any
violence and I find that kind of
entertaining I'm hoping this is more of
the comedy element that he went for in
the run down the comedy that he did
later with films like the tooth fairy
and stuff like it does look like a
Michael Bay movie all the over processed
colors the hot chicks and the slow
motion and the running and everything
and it looks like a Michael Bay movie it
does but it looks like a better Michael
Bay movie then the Michael Bay movies
we've gotten in the past except for the
rock which is awesome on May 3rd this is
the film that had to be in here of
course Iron Man 3 I'm looking forward to
this movie for many different reasons
for instance Shane Black as the director
gives me a lot of optimism I love the
fact that it's taking a different
direction as Iron Man 2 because new
writer new director that means an
entirely new look and feel and I'm
really hoping that this movie
revitalized this Iron Man because even
though Iron Man 2 wasn't awful it just
wasn't as good as the first one and this
series definitely needs a kick it needs
a kickstart and I'm really hoping that
Iron Man 3 is that needed jump this
series needs I'm excited to see what Ben
Kingsley does as the Mandarin I'm
excited to see if war machine can
actually be interesting in this point
I'm excited to see that cocky superhero
brought more down to level like he was
in the Avengers and I'd like to see that
even more on May 10th is a film that I
was already looking forward to for last
year but it was pushed back the great
gatsby this movie has Leonardo DiCaprio
Tobey Maguire Carey Mulligan this cast
is insane and I'm really looking forward
to it simply because of the visual
splendor it's always a very hard thing
to adapt a very famous book and there's
gonna be a lot of people who are
disappointed you are fans of the book
but I'm hoping that I'm not one of them
may 17th has star trek into darkness I
know virtually nothing about this movie
which is fantastic you guys know that I
like to go into a movie with a small
amount of knowledge as possible and I'm
really hoping this movie delivers
because JJ Abrams has a humongous future
in an already very successful career if
he's made in my opinion not one bad film
yet his TV efforts have been extremely
well-received and now he's directing
Star Wars after this just lets get this
movie here now I want to see it what's
going on with this movie I love the
first Star Trek let's see what he does
with a second when I'm pumped for it may
24th has Fast and the Furious 6 why am i
excited for the
movie in anyway because I thought the
fifth one was a lot of fun I thought it
was actually the best one of the entire
series are they all completely over the
top in every way with gravity defying
action in which every person in the film
should be dead countless times over of
course they are that's what these movies
are about the first four were kind of
yeah to me but the fifth one was just so
different it was like a great injection
of summer fuel and it got you all pumped
and ready for the summer and I'm hoping
that fast six does the exact same thing
now on June 7th comes the film that I am
NOT confident about but I am extremely
curious to see and I am just hoping that
it is good that is M night Shyamalan
after Earth obviously the man has lost a
step he started out incredibly he is
honestly probably the reason I'm even
talking to you guys right now on this
channel his first few films really
inspired me and actually got me into
filmmaking it made me love filmmaking
and film criticism and for that I owe
him quite a bit but the last few films
he's made have been pretty awful I'm
really truly hoping that after Earth is
not like that I just want to see if it
can be good and I hope it is Shyamalan I
got faith in you man I know you can make
a good movie let's do it June 14th one
of my top anticipated films of the year
is Man of Steel I need a good Superman
movie we need a good Superman movie
there hasn't been one in a while and I'm
really hoping it this is the one with
Zack Snyder at the helm and it looks
like he's really kind of reining himself
in Christopher Nolan's involved with
this film that definitely helps and I'm
truly hoping this is the Superman movie
that I've been waiting for for a while
I'm also extremely excited to see what
Hans Zimmer does with a Superman score
since it's not gonna be the Superman
theme because following up John Williams
Superman theme is like God made a
mountain and then he's like here's a
pebble make a mountain and you're like
thanks that theme is incredible I just
want to see what Hans Zimmer does
because he did an incredible job with
the Batman theme and I just I want to
see what else this guy can do now when
July 12th is a film that I'm also very
curious about but I'm not terribly
excited yet I need to see more but I am
very curious about Pacific Rim Guillermo
del Toro is directing this film it's
basically like Voltron and Godzilla
fighting and everything which sounds
incredible but I just I don't want it to
be like a transformers thing and I like
guillermo del toro he's made great films
and I don't think he'd ever do that but
I really want to see a Pacific Rim just
to see what the film is about I don't
like this general plot of the movie but
I just want to see how the film is and
how it feels is it more like a comic
book film is it more serious sci-fi is a
more fun sci-fi I'm just really curious
about this movie and I hope it's good
July 19th is a film that I'm interested
in purely because of the director the
conjuring by James Wan the maker of
insidious now this guy understands how
to scare the crap out of me because
insidious bothered me a lot I don't
really know anything about this movie
and I'm kind of staying away from all
details I just want to see a creepy
movie that gets under my skin and I'm
like oh that was some seriously
messed-up stuff not like violent or
disgusting I just wanna see I'm really
creepy suspenseful movie July 26 has
another one of my top anticipated films
of the year and that is the Wolverine
I'm looking forward to this movie for
similar reasons that I'm looking forward
to Iron Man 3 it looks like from what I
can tell and everything that I've heard
that they are taking this superhero who
has been in a ton of movies already
played by Hugh Jackman and basically
rebooting it even though it's still the
same actor they're basically giving it
an entirely new feel and look I'm very
glad that Hugh Jackman still in the role
because I really honestly think he is
Wolverine like he plays that character
so well August 9th has Elysium with Matt
Damon and Jodie Foster this is Neill
Blomkamp's next film after district 9
again don't know much about this movie
science fiction movie that's all I
really know I have stayed away from most
of the plot details I just know the
talent involved behind it which makes me
automatically interested in it Matt
Damon is good at picking scripts Jodie
Foster is good at picking scripts I'm
hoping this one is special I'm excited
to see Alecia August 30th has another
film by James Wan which relates very
much though to something I said earlier
insidious chapter 2 yes there's actually
a sequel to insidious this year and
that's pretty interesting because it
stars the same cast basically and
without spoiling anything if you have
not seen the first insidious that film
ended interestingly to say the least
what are they gonna do with the second
one I don't know all I know is that that
first film really creeped me out and it
was just a very different scary film for
me
and I'm looking forward to see what he
has up his sleeve this time September
27th has the pairing of two of the best
action stars ever the tomb with
Sylvester Stallone and Arnold
Schwarzenegger Stallone's in jail
Schwarzenegger is in jail they help each
other break out be good okay do not suck
that is an opportunity right there man
that is in serious opportunity for
awesomeness do not suck please now on
October 4th is actually two films coming
out I'm very excited for gravity and sin
city a dame to kill for gravity is
another film I know virtually nothing
about except that it comes from the
director of children of men that's all I
need to know when it stars George
Clooney and Sandra Bullock Sin City
honestly is one of the only Robert
Rodriguez films I've seen that I liked
in fact it felt like the only Robert
Rodriguez film that didn't feel like a
Robert Rodriguez film you know what I
mean it was extremely good and very
stylish and I'm hoping that Sin City 2
picks up right with the film left off in
a very good way and I'm really looking
forward to seeing it October 25th it's
Edgar Wright's new film the World's End
this also has Simon Pegg and Nick Frost
martin freeman as well and Rosamund Pike
Edgar Wright is a fantastic director he
has not made a bad film in all of his
films are so quirky it's so entertaining
and so stylish Lee directed Shauna the
Dead was incredibly good Hot Fuzz was
incredibly good Scott Pilgrim was
incredibly good if this films not
incredibly good it'll be weird because
they're all incredibly good on November
8th we have Thor the dark world now I'm
looking forward to this simply for one
reason it's a new Thor movie I don't
know much about this film it's a
different director that's probably good
because even though I like Kenneth
Branagh ha my word where there's so many
tilted angles and that poofy I'm hoping
there's a little bit less of that in
this next one I really like Chris
Hemsworth as Thor he is Thor to me now
he did a great job in the Avengers and
Thor I'm looking forward to see what
this movie has in store for us and
November 22nd is another film that I'm
not terribly pumped for simply because
the first film well good I just thought
it could have been a lot better but I am
excited to see if they can make the
series go in a different direction
because the director is changing how
Games Catching Fire first Hunger Games
film was good did not think it was great
though I wanted more out of it I'm
hoping that the second one gives me what
I need Jennifer Lawrence is a very good
actress I'm still not really a big fan
of Josh Hutcherson and I'm hoping that
this film can bring me what I need for
the Hunger Games Movies December 13th
has the Hobbit desolation of smaug part
2 in this trilogy as you guys know I
enjoyed the first Hobbit I wanted to
enjoy it more and I'm hoping that the
second one is a little bit more
condensed not so much stretching out of
stuff that's not necessarily in the book
and not defining every single detail I'm
also hoping it's not in 48 frames per
second but I'm hoping if the second one
blows my mind I really do I really want
the Hobbit to to blow my mind now on
December 20th if you want to ask me what
is my favorite Will Ferrell comedy I
would say Zoolander but since he's not
the main star of that film I'm gonna say
anchorman because anchorman has
literally endless quotable lines and I'm
looking forward to anchorman 2 I'm
hoping this film is as hilarious as the
first one I'm hoping that it's not like
wow we found something good here people
like let's just cash in on it I'm truly
hoping it's good I don't understand why
it's being released December 20th it
seems like an odd time for it I'm just
hoping that it is funny that's all I
want and on December 25th we have two
films I'm really interested in seeing 47
Ronin is a samurai film starring Keanu
Reeves
now wait okay what are you seven Ronin
is a samurai film starring Keanu Reeves
everything I've heard about it despite
the fact that it's been pushed back a
lot steam is really interesting to me
because if a film is bad you do not push
it back to Christmas Day that's not what
you've been pushing back to like January
or something and I like Keanu Reeves
even though he's not like the greatest
actor alive obviously he's still Keanu
Reeves and he's freaking awesome I mean
come on I love that guy Point Break
speed villain Ted the matrix let's do it
counter e's make a good samurai movie
please oh and lastly on the same day
December 25th is Jack Ryan the new
reboot of the character of Jack Ryan
played by Chris Pine also stars Kevin
Costner once again know nothing about
the movie simply interested because of
the talent involved because all the
previous incarnations of him whether he
was Alec Baldwin and Hunt for Red
October Harrison Ford and Patriot Games
are clear and present danger or Ben
Affleck in the Sun of all fears
and was not that great but the other
three were really good and I'm hoping
that it's more like those other three
and as you guys know I've already seen
the place beyond the pines terrific film
it's coming out in March can't wait for
you guys to see it that's why I didn't
mention it in this video however my most
anticipated film of the year I have not
yet mentioned simply because it does not
have an official release date yet
but to my knowledge is coming out in
2013 and that is Nicolas Winding
reference only God forgives starring
Ryan Gosling
I'm obviously excited for this movie
because it comes from the director of
Drive and has the exact same stars drive
please be incredibly good I'm just so
excited to see this movie there's
actually a 20 second teaser clip that
was kind of leaked online it's not even
an HD quality it is available on YouTube
the film looks incredible just from
those twenty seconds it looks when I and
when I say look I mean it really
honestly looks aesthetically amazing and
I'm hoping that the entire film is just
as good as Drive was if not better that
is my most anticipated film of the year
and it's killing me that I don't know
what the release date is nevertheless I
appreciate you guys watching this list
and as always if you like this and you
can click right here and get stuck
menage